[Music]
decision night in america
this election night will be historic no
matter who wins america's presidential
elections are global show stoppers
across presidential battlegrounds in
america alone
tens of millions tune in live to
election night coverage
this year will be like no other from
mass voting by mail
to hours-long weights of polling places
delayed results
and the rise of disinformation i'm john
fassbend the economist washington
correspondent
i've assembled a team of experts with
decades of experience with america's
electoral system
to discuss what could go wrong with this
year's election
difficult elections are not new for
america putting on a show of unity for
the cameras
but there's never been a presidential
election held during an epidemic that
has killed more than 200 000 americans
and involving a president with little
regard for democratic norms and
institutions
will you commit here today for a
peaceful transferal of power
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very trans we'll have
a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
the potential for chaos is huge
[Music]
i'd like to paint a scenario for you
it's election night maybe 65
70 percent of the mail-in ballots have
so far been counted
and donald trump holds a commanding lead
what are your worries about this
particular period of the election what
do you think might happen
if we're in a position where hundreds of
thousands or millions of ballots
in decisive states can't be counted
until after
election night that is going to be an
explosive situation
and i don't think telling voters to be
patient
the media saying wait it may be four
days it may be a week
i just don't think that's going to be
enough in the situation we face
the fact is is that there will be an
information vacuum on election night
we have an example from this election
cycle the iowa caucuses
the results weren't particularly clear
because the process was confused
let's think about that on steroids on
election night with
at least one candidate in particular who
we know will
is likely to lie about the results of
the election so
i will jump in what worries me is
where a significant number of americans
don't accept the outcomes is fair if we
don't
figure out a way to stave off these
problems or unless there are landslide
victories
across the country the immediate
aftermath of the election is going to
tear the country apart
primary elections held during the
epidemic have already shown what can go
wrong
the wisconsin primary on april 7th was
chaotic
they were short seven thousand poll
workers and many polling places were
closed
in november 2016 milwaukee the biggest
city in wisconsin
had 182 polling places in this year's
primary there were just
five was it easy to find this place mom
no it was very difficult how many miles
outside the city are we
two and a half miles we did a study of
turnout the turnout effect of
wisconsin's long lines in their april
primary
and found that more than that that those
long lines
depressed turn up by more than 8.3
percent and that those effects weren't
felt evenly across the board for
african-american voters in particular
turnout went down by more than 10
percent
those lines are leading to lost votes
[Music]
barriers to voting particularly for
non-white voters predate the epidemic
a complex patchwork of laws regulations
and practices
often place burdens that fall heaviest
on voters of color
even before covet 19 black and hispanic
voters were more likely than whites to
have to wait in line to cast their
ballots
between 2012 and 2018 almost 1700
polling places closed
most of those were in majority minority
areas
monet you were waging one of the most
important voting rights fights
in perhaps the most important state in
america what are you seeing
on the ground in a state like florida
voter suppression does
begin before we even make it to the
ballot box we've seen precinct locations
being moved without notification
being sent to voters we've seen voters
removed simply because
their last names were ethnic sounding
and there was some
fear that they may not be eligible to
vote
this year non-whites make up a third of
the american electorate
the highest ever share there are a lot
of votes to be won
or lost organizations like monet holders
new florida majority
are taking the fight for voting access
to the courts
the most recent litigation actually
began in march when the pandemic
first hit and we filed to do an
emergency injunction
to expand the timeline for early voting
and for returning ballots and requesting
them
there are at least 228 court cases
pending in i think 43 states dc and
puerto rico
rick is that an unusual amount of cases
this is of course
unprecedented we've never seen this
level of litigation
in advance of an election the litigation
is being brought by political parties
and their affiliates
these lawsuits mainly concern changes to
voting rules brought about by the
epidemic
one of the biggest concerns is the rise
in voting by mail
in 2016 voting by mail was not widely
used
as many states required voters to
provide an excuse for why they couldn't
vote in person
but in this election almost all states
will allow voting by mail
with either no excuse needed or with
fear of contracting covet 19 as a valid
excuse
and nine states in washington dc are
even mailing a ballot to every
registered voter
yet many underfunded electoral districts
are woefully unprepared
states have experienced challenges in
accommodating that surge
and voters are votes are being lost
along the way for failure to process
absentee ballots on time for
mail delays where people don't receive
them on time
and for counting problems where states
are
unable to or are rejecting a an
inordinately large number of those
ballots compared to
usual years right now we're predicting
that we'll have about 4.2 million
absentee
ballots or vote by mail ballots in
florida and we're scared
that the postal service may not deliver
them there may not be enough
poll workers within our county election
offices to actually hand
open and process those
[Music]
despite the concerns voting by mail
remains the safest way to vote in an
epidemic
but you wouldn't know that if you listen
to president trump
mail-in ballots are very dangerous
there's tremendous fraud involved and
tremendous
illegality this will be in my opinion
the most corrupt election
in the history of our country and we
cannot
let this happen
no evidence exists that supports the
president's claims
and studies have shown that voting by
mail boosts turnout
but favors neither party the strategy
here
that we've seen play out over the last
few weeks is based on
misleading people about how to vote
disinformation about not only
the results of the election but also
when where and how to vote
do you think donald trump is doing the
russians job for them this cycle
i think that donald trump is is doing a
very good job of not being burdened by
facts about our democracy
what we've seen from actors like russia
is a
willingness to kind of exploit that to
stop creating their own
content and frankly just take existing
content and amplify it a little bit more
is trump's rhetoric harming sort of
perceptions of fairness in this election
absolutely voters are in fear that their
votes will not be counted
our greatest worry is that being in the
midst of a global pandemic
voters will feel that they have to
either choose between their health
and participating in democracy and with
all other things considered
they may choose to sit this one out as
usual there's a
you know kernel of truth on which this
whole edifice of
disinformation is built there are going
to be some glitches
um some meltdowns some lines some lost
votes
but the magnitude of it is much
smaller than being made to believe and
if americans
vote early that should mitigate
any of these problems
according to the economist model as of
the end of september
president trump is unlikely to win a
second term
but there is still over a month to go
and the contest is likely to tighten
and grow more heated in 2000
when the supreme court ruled in favor of
george w bush
al gore graciously stepped aside this
has been an extraordinary election
its very closeness can serve to remind
us that we are one people
with a shared history and a shared
destiny
the loser in this year's contest may not
bow out so gracefully
and that could have a lasting impact on
the esteem in which both americans and
the world hold the country's democracy
[Music]
i'm john fassman the economist
washington correspondent
with election day less than six weeks
away you can join me and my colleagues
from the us
team for a live digital event we're
hosting especially for economist readers
and viewers
we'll be discussing the economic impact
of the election and answering any
questions you might have about the rest
of the campaign
the event is completely free to register
just click on the link
thank you for watching
you